>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Grant Harris: Well good
afternoon, I am Grant Harris,
I am head of the European
Reading Room here
at the Library of Congress.
And I welcome you to
the European Division,
we're here in the European Division
conference room and we're going
to listen to Jonathan Kapiloff speak
about quantifying the Soviet
economic and social crisis of 1920,
food supply, rail transport,
fuel and demographics.
Mr. Kapiloff has earned his BA
in 1980 from Columbia University
where he studied under the notable
historian of Russia Mark Raeff.
He earned his MA and C Phil
degree in 1984 from the University
of California at Berkeley
where he studied
under notable historians Nicholas
Riasanovsky and Martin Malia.
Now this is really a kind
continuation if you will of a talk
that Jonathan gave last year,
really a brilliant talk here
in this same room November
12 of 2015.
That talk was entitled
the Geography of Hunger,
how Lenin handled Russia's food
supply crisis of winter 1919/1920.
And we're very happy to have
Jonathan back here again.
Jonathan has done some really
deep research using Library
of Congress resources
and we're very pleased
to have him uncover all these
resources that we have and make use
of them and he's a good
speaker as you will see.
So Jonathan, I'll turn this over
to you, thank you for being here.
>> Jonathan Kapiloff:
Great, thanks very much
for the very kind introduction,
I think it may have been
a little too charitable.
I do want to stress that
this talk is a thematic
and historical continuation of
the talk I gave last November
that was mainly focused
on food supply.
And a significant part of
this talk will come back
to food supply later on in the hour.
>> Grant Harris: Let me just ask
can you hear okay from there?
>> Jonathan Kapiloff: Yeah.
But the focus of this is going to
be more on the issue of transport
and fuel and really the
crisis and near collapse
of the entire Russian Soviet
rail network by early 1920.
And so what I want to emphasize
from the beginning and again,
I could not be more thankful to
the Library of Congress for this,
is that I've mainly been
working almost exclusively really
with primary source materials
from the period 1919, 1920.
I've used a couple of
primary source materials
and actually a key monograph
that was published in 1922
and that monograph in
1922, which is very,
very rare volume helped
me tie all this together.
But again, what I've seen is that
there's a trance amount of material,
primary source material printed
at the time that I consider
to be very reliable in terms of
information about what was going
on both quantitatively and
qualitatively during this period.
So I really want to try
to share with everyone
and especially the library staff
give them a sense of the uniqueness
and special quality of a lot of
these primary source materials.
That's really one of
the main things I want
to accomplish in the talk today.
I'm here to give a narrative on
this subject that I've talked about
and according to the title.
But I'd also like to address three
other questions and if I haven't,
then I kind of left everyone
hanging a little bit in terms
of what this primary
source material offers.
And so in addition to talking
about demography, food supply
and especially about
the transport system
and specifically the
rail transport system I'd
like to answer three questions.
One is the role that wood played
during the Civil War and I'm going
to spend a lot of time on that.
If one can't understand
the role that wood played
as crucial fuel during the Civil
War period, especially compared
to what existed prior to 1917 you
really can't get an understanding
of what was going on
in European Russia
and especially how the
peasants were living
and what the state expected
of peasants at the time.
Two other questions I want to
address are what was Lenin's role
in all of this, but I wanted to
focus again on what was going
on qualitatively and quantitatively
and then bring Lenin back
in towards the very end.
And then finally and although
it has pejorative connotation
and I don't mean it this way,
I wanted to answer the question
of something that was discussed
at the time it had a specific
connotation the phrase I'm
about to use in 1920.
The English translation is those
who do not work they shall
not eat [foreign language].
What did that mean?
It had a very specific
policy connotation,
it honestly has potentially
much more pejorative connotation
in the context of the Civil War
and lack of food and so forth.
But in the process of
this talk I want to try
to answer those questions as well.
Let me just start by saying
that I do feel that the amount
of primary source material
here at the Library of Congress
for the period 1919, 1920 has
been vastly underappreciated,
that's what I've been working with.
I'm not here to make
comparisons with other libraries
or brother institutions,
I've done a lot of work
in the former Soviet Union,
I also did a lot of work
at the Hoover Institution.
I do believe that there
are several volumes here
that are probably unique
in Western libraries.
I don't think I could have put
together the picture that I am going
to try to present to you today
without having access to the Hoover
and then some very special
things that are here
at the Library of Congress.
And just to give you one example
the library has a complete run
in the original of the bulletin
of the People's Commissar
to Transport issues numbers
1 through 288, the entire run
for calendar year 1920,
it's really remarkable.
And without materials like
that I wouldn't have been able
to put together the presentation
that I'm about to give to you.
So what I wanted to start and this
is not meant as a review it's meant
to compare and contrast
what was going
on immediately before World
War 1 and then I'm going
to move forward briefly to the
war itself and then to 1920
to give you a sense
of what was going
on with transport and
specifically fuel.
So I'm just going to step to the
map here and give a quick synopsis
of some things that happened
going back even before 1914
at the beginning of World War 1.
And I'm going to point to the city
of Baku here on the Caspian Sea.
And Baku was really the first
center in the entire world
where oil was not only discovered,
but started to be produced
in industrial quantities.
It even proceeded a lot of what
happened in the United States
in the development of standard
oil under the Rockefellers.
And this is documented it
was such a major development
in the world economy that it's not
just something to be documented
in narrow Russian sources.
If anyone has read the
key book called The Prize
by Daniel Yergin they will know
that Baku is where oil first started
to be used on a
commercial/industrial level.
And that was in the late
1870's, very early 1880's.
And what happened was
beginning around 1880
and this was a key
technological breakthrough
as well oil is transported from Baku
a couple hundred miles along the
Caspian Sea to the mouth
of the Volga River.
And from there it was
carried up the Volga by boat,
stopped in major cities [inaudible],
Saratov, Samara, Kazan, [inaudible]
and then eventually made its way
either by river or later by train
to Moscow and Saint Petersburg.
This is before the end of the 20th
century in very, very large amounts.
And I have in my handout a separate
explanation of Russian weights
and measurements that existed
at the time of the revolution,
prior to the revolution, through the
revolution, through the Civil War.
And the key Russian
measurement was a pood
which was approximately 36 pounds.
And so from one of the
sources that I have,
although there were contemporary
resources before Word War 1.
I just wanted to mention
how many millions of poods
of oil was transported from Baku
on the Caspian Sea up to the mouth
of Volga near [inaudible] and then
subsequently up the Volga, Moscow,
Saint Petersburg, all the other
major parts of European Russia.
So in 1912 and the source for
this is a special volume here
at the Library of Congress
called [inaudible],
it was a journal published by the
Supreme Council of National Economy.
So an article that
appeared in 1920 talks
about in 1912 268 million
poods of oil were transported
from the Caspian up
to the Volga River
and [inaudible] subsequently up.
In 1913 270 million poods, 1914 244
million poods, 1915 first full year
of World War 1 increased 319 million
poods, 1916 337 million poods.
Then as the war took more of a toll
on Russia a lot of men were drafted,
there were labor shortages.
In 1917 it fell to
280 million poods.
Now here is the real
introduction to my talk.
In 1918 it went from 280
million poods in 1917
down to 74 and in 1919 it was zero.
The reason being that
with the conflict going
on during the Civil War
the Volga River was cut
at that time actually initially by
some Czech forces who were there
to participate on the
Russian front in World War 1.
And really what happened during
most of the Civil War was
that the Soviet Regime
did not have access
to Baku oil, there was no oil.
And so that had tremendous
consequences for the entire economy.
The numbers that I
cited should indicate
that prerevolutionary Russia,
Russia during World War I and even
at the beginning of 1917 was a
very, very oil dependent economy.
It was not as an advanced economy
overall industrially as countries
in Western Europe, but there
was a very advanced oil economy
and a transport economy.
And one of the things that is
discussed in many sources I've seen
and it's referred to in Daniel
Yergin's book is that really
by 1890's large amounts
of foreign capital,
names that we would recognize.
The Nobel family the Rothschild
family they were investing very
heavily in this entire industry
and the transport of oil
up the Volga very,
very large investments.
The Nobels and Rothschilds actually
controlled most of the production
and the transport of oil
along the Caspian Sea
up the Volga and then into Russian.
>> Grant Harris: And what
time did it start this?
>> Jonathan Kapiloff: It was
certainly by 1900, certainly by 1900
and there's a very pronounced
change with each passing decade.
Beginning around 1890 it's a
lot more than it was in 1880,
it really got started in
late 1870's, early 1880's,
the 1900's is already a
benchmark compared to 1890.
Now I don't want to
create the impression here
that the [inaudible] economy
was stronger than it really was,
the country as a whole had a
lot of very serious and social
and economic problems and just it's
kind of something very interesting
that Yergin points out in his book.
But because of rising
anti-Semitism in 1912
and it was probably a
very good business move
in retrospect the Rothschilds
basically withdrew almost all their
investments, so they
were not expropriated
at the time of the revolution.
I don't believe that was the
same case with the Nobel family.
The other thing that I wanted to
talk about was the development
of the coal industry and this is
an area that's now been recently
in the news, mainly in the
Donetsk basin in Eastern Ukraine.
And so without going into a
long synopsis of the development
of the Russian rail system the
Eastern Ukraine became a major
source of coal that powered
the Russian rail system.
And I want to talk about some other
areas that also produced coal and go
over some economic geography.
But from what I believe is a
unique source here at the Library
of Congress published in
1922 I have information
about how much coal was
produced and used in Russia.
So in 1903, use of coal by
Russian rail network was
over a billion poods,
again a pood is 36 pounds.
By 1913 and again, Russia had a lot
of economic and social problems,
issues about revolution
and social justice.
But the fact is by 1913, what was
slightly over a billion poods used
by the Russian rail network in 1903
that had more than doubled by 1913,
as well as the length of the
Russian rail network, excuse me.
Now I also want to stress that
while there's a tremendous amount
of coal production in the Eastern
Ukraine there was so much demand
for coal in the Russian economy
that coal was imported by England.
I don't know whether it
was from Newcastle or not,
but a tremendous amount of coal
was imported into Saint Petersburg.
Most of the coal that was
used in Saint Petersburg
for heating actually
came from England.
And there was also coal from
England that was imported
to feed the Russian rail network and
to power the Russian rail network.
So these are two kind of key
geographical economic facts
of what happened prior
to the revolution.
And I'm going to skip forward
for one second and indicate
and I'll give more of the detail
about this that as a result
of the revolution and the Civil War
the Soviet Regime really did not
have access to Donetsk coal.
A couple of other places that
should be mentioned in terms
of the poor economic background
for what I'm going to start talking
about 1920 in a few minutes is
that there were [inaudible] sources
of coal in the Ural Mountains near
Chelyabinsk and north of there.
There was also coal
in Western Siberia
and Western Siberia really isn't
on this map, we're getting close,
but it's not included in this map.
And so those sources of coal
were used and prior to 1914,
certainly 1917 the vast majority of
the Russian rail network used coal.
There was some use of wood,
wood was much harder to use,
much less energy-efficient
than either coal or oil.
But basically by 1914 and according
to this mini chronograph I found
here at the Library of Congress,
around 75% of the Russian rail
network was powered by coal,
around 10% by oil and there's a
way to power locomotives using oil,
and then approximately
5 to 10% by wood.
But all of the main rail
connections in European Russia,
the major rail routes use coal
or oil, wood was used only
on local lines or in
Siberia in particular
because there was a
lot of wood in Siberia.
And so one of the things I want to
talk about just getting back briefly
to this oil be transported
from Baku up to the mouth
of the Volga River is that
initially when [inaudible] came
to the Volga River it used
wood, wood was the source.
It was only after 1880 that you had
use of oil to power the Volga fleet.
And as you see the
development of the Volga fleet,
especially after 1890
and into the beginning
of the 20th century it is
making leaps and bounds in terms
of how energy-efficient it is
and how much cargo it can carry.
So for instance in 1914 there
are over 200 million poods
of various grains that
were conveyed up the Volga.
And basically in 1903 Rudolf
Diesel licensed the diesel engine
to the Nobel family.
And you have the initial
construction of diesel tugboats.
Some of these diesel tugboats on the
Volga could carry as much on barges
at one time, just one diesel engine
tugboat carrying several large
barges, 500,000 poods of grain.
That would be the equivalent
of 500 rail cars of grain.
There is a recognition from a
lot of material both primary
and secondary before the revolution
during 1917 and afterwards
that one railcar, standard
Russian railcar,
could carry around a thousand poods
of grain, which is 36,000 pounds
so approximately 18 tons.
So you had a tremendous increase
in the intensity and efficiency
of the Volga commercial fleet in
terms of delivering many things.
Not just grain, but all kinds of
building supplies, raw materials,
salt, many other things that
were needed by the economy.
And what we'll see is that by 1920
the Soviet Regime had been going
for an entire full-year, for all of
1919 and really a good part of 1918
as well, would have access to
any sources of coal or oil.
And so I think one of the things
that has really not been appreciated
in history of what was going
during the Civil War period was
that the economy really became
entirely dependent on wood.
Wood is a much more inefficient
source of energy than oil or coal.
It is very hard to use wood as
the main source for locomotives
and that was the underlying
reason why there was
such a large transport crisis
in the Soviet control territory
in European Russia by 1920.
And in fact, what I found in
all of these sources and it's --
I'm going to make an argument
people may want to swat me for it,
but I'm going to make an argument
that [inaudible] Izvestia are very,
very important sources
for understanding what
was going on at the time.
And not only in [inaudible]
Izvestia,
but all of the primary
source materials I found here
at the Library of Congress they
always talk about the use of wood
and they convert it
to what they believed
and they had good scientific
basis for this,
they may be approximations.
What was the equivalent energy
use of either coal or oil
and especially dealing
with railroads they talk
about the equivalent
wood used and what
that would have amounted to in coal.
And so I'm also going to explain
in April 1920 the local Azeri
government Baku which was supported
by the British, the Red Army
eventually captured Baku
in late April 1920.
And all of a sudden there
is a change in the picture.
A country that has not had access to
oil suddenly has some access to oil.
It's limited amounts, but it changes
the whole economic perspective
of what is going on.
And it doesn't mean that
everything changes immediately,
in fact it doesn't and I will
skip ahead and say for instance,
that at least through the
end of 1920, well into 1921
and beyond wood remained
the single largest source
for powering the Russian
rail network.
And that's what the Soviet Regime
had to deal with was this gathering
of wood, the transporting of
wood and getting this wood
to local rail depots,
local rail lines.
Procuring wood is a very, very
difficult thing in large amounts.
It has to be chopped, it
has to best transported.
There are two ways really of
transporting wood in large volumes
of the type that a real
network would need.
You either need to send
it down rivers or you have
to have peasants haul it.
And so one of the main things
that peasants did for the regime
and basically was a form of labor
conscription was hauling wood
so that the rail system could work.
The other way to do it if you
send it downriver has its downside
and this is discussed
a tremendous amount
in the primary source materials
is the wood has a certain amount
of humidity in that it is that
much more difficult to burn
in the boiler of a locomotive.
And there are numerous references to
the fact that boilers either explode
or break because the wood that is
being put into them is too humid.
These are kind of what may
sound like small details,
but when you look at them from
a larger picture and realize
that wood was the main source
for the Russian rai network really
beginning the 1918 you get a sense
of what people were really
dealing with in trying
to make this transport system work.
So I wanted to just -- I've given
a handout and in in the handout,
one of the handouts I talked
about and I'm just going
to summarize it quickly here
if I can find the right page here
what are the energy equivalents
of wood compared to oil and coal.
And it's very, very interesting
because and I found it
on the last page of the
handout key Russian weights
and measurements used at
the time of the revolution
and during the Civil War period.
And basically because there
were other sources of coal other
than the coal here
in the Donetsk basin
in Eastern Ukraine
it's very interesting.
So it basically say the basic
measurement for wood was not
by weight it was by volume and
it was called a cubic sazhen.
I've been trying to find out exactly
what a cubic sazhen equaled in terms
of volume, I've seen
references in the law library,
a special volume there that I think
is unique to the Library of Congress
that one railcar could hold
2.3 cubic sazhens of wood.
But whatever it was one cubic
sazhen of wood was equivalent
to a hundred poods or approximately
3,600 pounds of Donetsk coal.
It was also equal to 100
poods of Siberian coal.
And there was coal in the
[inaudible] as I mentioned.
[Inaudible] coal was less
rich as an energy source
than Siberian or Donetsk coal.
So one cubic sazhen it took
150 poods of [inaudible] coal
to equal one cubic sazhen of wood.
There was some very
low-grade coal near Moscow.
That was the only coal that
the regime had access to.
And so coal from Moscow, it took 250
poods of coal from the Moscow basin
to equal one cubic sazhen of wood.
And then what is very, very
interesting is it took only 70 poods
of oil to be the equivalent
of cubic sazhen of wood.
So I'm also going to mention just
briefly two key data points here
that give you a sense
of what was going
on with the Russian rail network
and what a tremendous
difficulty it presented
for running the entire economy.
First of all and this is
in several primary sources,
this is also mentioned in the key
article in [inaudible] by the head
of the [inaudible] Fuel
Administration a guy named Alexander
Lomov is it took one full
railcar of wood to move a train
that was carrying let's
say 11 to 12 cars
of either grain, wood, whatever.
It took one full railcar
of wood to move that train
and the cars it was carrying
a hundred [inaudible],
which is only 66 miles.
So if you wanted -- here's
Moscow, here is [inaudible],
the distance from Moscow to
[inaudible] is approximately 275,
to Kazan it's around 500 miles.
If you wanted to move a
train from Kazan to Moscow
and you weren't going to pick up
any wood on route you need to have
in effect five railcars just
full of wood to get it that far.
That gives you some sense
of the inefficiencies
and the huge headache
quite frankly of trying
to make a rail system
like this work.
It's very interesting, after
Baku was captured by the Red Army
in late April 1920 there are
numerous references to the fact
that those railcars which can be
converted to oil because again,
there's no coal available
or very little coal only
from the Moscow basin,
some from the [inaudible].
There is a reference to once
they can start reconverting some
of these locomotives to
oil use it would more
than double the efficiency of what's
involved in transporting any cargo.
And there's a specific reference
to we can use twice the number
of locomotives than we could before
to transport very scarce food
supplies, especially grain.
So can see from some of these key
data points how the transport system
really constructed
the entire economy
and I've got a lot
more to say about that.
But if you just start from those
data points you start to be able
to see what it looked like for
the people living at the time
and you get a sense of
what Lenin and the people
and the People's Commissar
of Transport
and [inaudible] People's
Commissar of Transport for most
of 1920 what they were dealing with
in trying to make this beast work.
It is really something
that is almost unimaginable
and what I would say
just to sum up this part
of my presentation is you can see
that in many ways European Russia
under Soviet control and there's
a separate editorial comment
which I don't want to get into how
much might have been [inaudible]
fault for this, not their
fault, was it circumstances,
I'm not here to editorialize
on that.
But you can see that if you
look at where things were
in 1920 just given some of
the data points I've cited
that this is a country
that went back to a time
at least 50 years in its past.
It may not have been
as advanced as a lot
of Western European countries
industrial and otherwise,
but it had a very, very
advanced oil industry.
The economy was very dependent on
the use of oil in factories, coal,
the rail transport
system, etcetera, etcetera
and basically what happened was
the Soviet Regime had to deal
with the situation where they
were trying to manage an economy
and run the country
that had gone more
than 50 years back
into its economic past.
And wood was really what this was
about it's how did you procure
the wood, how did you transport
to rail depots and rail lines, how
did you line up enough railcars
of wood if you had to move
a train let's say 400 miles,
that's a lot of verst, a verst
is .66 miles approximately.
So what I want to say is and I'm
going to go into more detail later,
I'm starting to run short on
time already is that by 1920,
by really late 1919, the Civil
War in effect is over militarily,
there's a war separately
between Soviet Russia and Poland.
But in terms of the white armies
that whether they had
democratic roots
or these so-called
counterrevolutionary forces they
were more people representing
the land of gentry,
wanted to get back their property.
The Civil War had really
come to an end
by October 1919, late October 1919.
At one point white forces
had cut off the Volga River
that was in 1918.
They were pushed back.
During the spring of
1919 they came very close
to the Volga, but did
not cut it off.
In the spring of 1919 Anton Denikin
organized a major military push
out of the Ukraine in
the direction of Moscow,
he got within 250 miles of Moscow.
But in late October before he
got to the key town of Kaluga
where there were major
arms [inaudible]
that supplied the Red
Army [inaudible]
and that was basically late 1919.
So basically what happened
by the beginning of 1920
as you find this situation
where there is a perception
by the Soviet Regime that they
need to worry about Poland,
there's an understanding that
Poland could be a future aggressor,
but for the first time there's
really very little in terms
of real military action
going on between the Red Army
and various white forces wherever
they were coming whether it was
Siberia, the [inaudible],
the Ukraine, so forth.
The military conflict isn't over,
but Kolchak is being pushed very far
back in Siberia very, very quickly.
He's surrendering, a lot of
his forces are giving up.
Denikin is quickly falling back
[inaudible] was in Ukraine.
There was kind of a last
stand in the Crimea,
but really for all intents
and purposes the military
conflict is over.
And so what I found the single
most important source I ever found
about the Civil War in
terms of what was going
with the economy what
[inaudible] regime had to deal
with once this was all over was
something almost found by chance,
it wasn't even in the main catalog,
it was in the [inaudible] catalog.
And it was a key meeting
that happened
on the 25th of January 1920.
I believe this is a unique document,
I'm not a bibliographer
I'll leave it
to the bibliographers
to try to figure it out.
But basically it was a key meeting
in Moscow, I believe that there were
at least 5 or 600 people attending,
had key speeches by Alexei Rykov,
Trotsky I'm sure you've
heard of, some other people.
And it says on the out of
this, it's only 34 pages,
this was copy forwarded
by American July 30, 1920,
that's what's on the cover here.
This was a meeting that
happened approximately five
and a half months earlier
on January 25th.
And basically I've never seen a
meeting or a speech like this,
although there was a lot
of very open talk while
[inaudible] were censored,
it is remarkable how
much openness there was
and what they talked about.
But this speech mainly by
Alexei Rykov who's head
of the Supreme Council of National
Economy he speaks as someone
who believes in the communist
regime and in the communist project.
But it's really couched in
terms that anyone who believes
in the market economy of
any kind, whether capitalist
or whatever wouldn't
have given this speech.
And what Rykov says in this speech
is that the economy is destroyed.
And then he proceeds to give a
lot of key data points for that.
One of the things that I've read,
kind of one of the most famous
histories of the Civil War period
by Edward Carr talks in
general terms about the fact
that the economy declined by two
thirds between 1917 and 1923.
And there's a general
recognition by all historians
that what the revolution
and Civil War did
to Soviet Russia economically
was a disaster,
it was basically a
complete collapse.
But Rykov really puts some
meat on the bones of this
that I think is unique and
makes that [inaudible].
So one of the things he says is he
says that because of the collapse
of the transport system and then
Trotsky also supports him on this
and in some important
articles contributes
to [inaudible] is Rykov
says we're here in Moscow,
the Soviet Regime kind of controls
the central European part of Russia.
But he says that we have no
contact with [inaudible].
We don't have enough trains, we
can't make them work well enough
and the [inaudible] is
basically a separate economy,
it's been largely destroyed
or to a very large extent
destroyed during the Civil War.
But if we wanted to import iron
ore from the [inaudible] to Moscow
and make metal Moscow and in Saint
Petersburg factories right now given
the amount of trains and transport
capacity we have it would take us
many decades to just
get that started.
And then he says, there was
a very large textile industry
in Russia before the revolution.
He said if we wanted to take the
cotton from Uzbekistan and bring it
to Moscow and Saint Petersburg
and there were large numbers
of unemployed textile workers he
said that would take 20 years.
So what the discussion about in this
long speech by Rykov and he talks
about the destruction of
national wealth almost
as if he was a market economist.
There are there other
references and other things.
But what he says is there's
a tremendous destruction
of national wealth
here and the fact is
that the transport system is
not something that allows us
to recreate this whole
national economy
that existed before World War 1
and that clearly had suffered
a lot during the course
of World War 1 as well.
I don't want to minimize
the importance of that.
And so what he's saying is we don't
have the trains to bring the grain
from the Volga region
to central Russia.
These are basically grain deficit
areas, they don't grow enough grain
to feed the local population.
We don't have the trains to bring
the coal from Eastern Ukraine
to make our locomotives work.
And so the question is at the
beginning of 1920, is it possible
to basically stitch together the
whole country, is it possible.
And they really want to rule out
is it possible at all and then B,
if it is possible how do we do it.
And one of the interesting things
that Rykov cites is
he says specifically
and I'm not an economist, I'm not
here to get into economic statistics
or how much did the economy
decline I'm much more interested
in the qualitative
aspects of what was going
on with some important
quantitative measurements.
But Rykov does cite the fact
that the economy has
declined by two thirds.
He does use that number.
And then he cites another
very scary statistic,
he says that because we
don't have access to oil,
this is in early 1920, we
lack all the lubricants
that we need to do railroad repairs.
We can't feed the workers who
would be fixing locomotives
because they've run
away to the countryside,
that's where the food is,
there's no real food in Moscow
because trains can't bring it
there in sufficient quantities.
And so it's kind of a Rubik's cube
how do you start putting this all
back together.
And he cites in addition to the
constraints that I mentioned
about how much wood do you need
to make things move and, you know,
you need one railcar of
wood just to move one
of these trains a 100
verst or 66 miles.
But what happens is that because
there's been no ongoing repairs
of locomotives for many years now
and it started to really decline
in 1914, he cites the
fact that he believes
and there are no exact
numbers it's a period
of really tremendous economic chaos.
He says we believe at this
point we have 3,800 locomotives
that are operational.
They may not be in good repair,
but at least they're moving.
They may need repairs,
but we're down to 3,800.
The number in 1914 of locomotives
that were available was 20,000.
And there was a lot of information
in all these primary resource
materials, what were the number
of locomotives that were
produced in 1919, it was 149.
In the years before the revolution
and there are a lot of statistics
in these Soviet journals from
1920 that are unique here
at the Library I believe
in terms of complete set,
the economy was building up a
thousand locomotives a year.
And so there was a key article in
Pravda that raises the question,
it's a logical question I haven't
seen it addressed anyplace else,
at what point do we get to a number
of locomotives as they're declining
where we can't really
effectively move anything.
It may be that the [inaudible]
are a separate economy themselves,
the Ukraine is a separate economy,
there's a wish to bring grain
from Siberia because Western
Siberia is actually a net grain
producing area.
That comes up later in the 20's
I don't want to get into it
when Stalin wants to get more grain
he goes after the [inaudible],
it's called the [inaudible]
Siberian method.
He's after extra grain in the
[inaudible] and in Western Siberia.
And Western Siberia
probably had a grain surplus
of around 100 million poods a year.
Lenin is very interested
in that let me assure you.
But the problem is even if
they could get their hands
on it how do you transport this
when one railcar will
take you 66 miles okay.
That's assuming you have
the wood to begin with.
So what I found in this key article
in Pravda is the question is asked
specifically, what's the number
where the system no longer
works at all, it's very much
on the verge of collapse.
And a very interesting fellow writes
an article in Pravda and says,
if we get to 2,500 it's over, we
shouldn't even start trying anymore,
there's going to be no more economy,
you know, there won't be a regime.
And there's a lot of open discussion
about can the regime survive.
The word in Russian [foreign
language] is used throughout these
primary source documents.
On a couple of occasions Lenin
uses it, it's rare, but he uses it.
He even makes reference to the way
things were at the end of 1919,
the regime cannot continue
that way he says it
in a key speech that's included
in his collective works.
So what Rykov explains at this key
meeting at the American Consulate
in [inaudible] is that he
thinks they have around 3,800,
2,500 seems to be kind
of the barrier
where you can just forget about it.
And the concern is is that with each
passing month there are 200 less
working locomotives every month.
So they start doing projections
that if it keeps going this way
by the end of 1920 there's
nothing more to talk about.
That's why there are
these discussions
about it's a fight for survival.
They use the word [foreign
language] in Russian fight,
they use the word [foreign
language] survival.
And so really what happens and
I know time is short here is
that Trotsky takes the lead,
Trotsky is really the key person
in 1920 other than Lenin.
And Trotsky comes up with a plan
how do we start repairing these
locomotives, how do we do that.
And what you see is there
is a period of late,
I know this sounds very
specific, but there's a period
in late February 1920 until
approximately the first weeks
of April where everyone is
questioning whether the regime
will survive.
And it's in exactly that
time that Lenin, Trotsky,
the whole senior Bolshevik
leadership makes a very concerted
effort to turn this around and I
have some statistics in the handbook
and it starts to show
that this decline
of approximately 200
locomotives a month is staunched,
they're just starting to hold even.
And then as you get into summer
1920 Trotsky as commissar
of transport starts to
really turn this around.
Not in a big way it doesn't get
them a lot of breathing room,
but the fact that the regime
is on life support it's
on the precedence that
comes to an end.
They're not making the rail system
as a whole work a whole lot better,
but there's no longer a sense
our necks are on the block
that is just not the case.
So I'm running a little
short on time.
I wanted to say a couple
things about Trotsky.
The Library here has
Trotsky's complete works
or close approximation
to them were published.
The Library has a complete,
has all of the volumes.
Volume 15, which I
know may sound esoteric
that covers everything
he did in 1920.
And basically what Trotsky did
in late May 1920 as commissar
of transport was he issued
what became a famous order,
it was called order number 1042.
And that was an industrial
plan to produce spare parts
so that these locomotives
could be fixed.
And in the meantime, they're
starting to get a little trickle
of oil from Baku by summer 1920
and it's coming up the Volga
and they're starting to make,
they're starting to refigure
and redo some of the locomotives
that could only use wood.
And they're starting to see
tremendous advantages from that.
They're not really getting
Donetsk coal and I've included
in the document in the handout
that shows as late as October 1920,
only a 10th of the mine
workers that were working
in the Donetsk coal basin
before World War 1 were employed
at that time.
So the maximum amount
that it produced was 1/10.
There was a tremendous amount
of chaos and economic anarchy
in the Ukraine, a lot of
fighting back and forth.
When the Pols did attack in
April, May 1920 they got very far
into Ukraine, they actually captured
Kiev, they didn't get that far.
Stalin was in the Ukraine for most
of 1920 and his goal was to try
to restore the coal
industry in the Ukraine.
When the Pols attacked
his focus was much more
on the military side of things.
So what I wanted to just talk about
briefly and this is what I think one
of the key things I got out of all
the primary source documents I used
here I do think the documents at
the Hoover are very important,
the things I got in the Soviet
archives are very important too is
that there were three key government
bodies throughout the course of 1920
that made policy, debated
policy, etcetera, etcetera.
And those were basically the
Soviet hierarchy, the senior part
of that was the Council
Peoples Commissars.
Lenin was chairman of the
Council Peoples Commissar,
so under Council People Commissar
you had the commissar of transport,
you had the commissar of the
food supply, etcetera, etcetera.
And then obviously you
had the Communist Party
and there was a Politburo.
The Politburo really
made overarching general
policy decisions.
So when the Pols attacked for
instance questions about how
that attack should be handled
in general terms were decided
by the Politburo, but the Politburo
really didn't do a lot more
than that.
The key institution and when I was
at Columbia this was [inaudible]
always suggests, always emphasized
to me is that if you can get a hold
of kind of the institutional history
of what was going on
you can really kind
of almost decode the most
important things after that.
And what happens in early February,
although it's going this direction
in January at the time of
the speech that I referred
to is Lenin reinforces what was
previously called the Council
of Defense.
The Council of Defense coordinated
all defensive industrial activity
as the Red Army fought the white
armies really up until October 1919.
And what Lenin and Trotsky decide
and this is as much Trotsky
as Lenin is they decide that
the council of defense has
to be expanded and it's renamed
the Council of Labor and Defense.
And so what happens
during the course of 1920
and there's a very good book that
goes into the research of this,
it's the translation of English,
there's an English translation.
It's documents from the Hoover
Institution called the Origin
of Forced Labor in the
Soviet State 1917-1921
if you just want to pass it around.
The Council of Labor and Defense
actually becomes the key central
economic organ to deal with
this mess that I've described,
the transport system, lack of
food, the demographic issues
of workers running away from
the main industrial centers
and then factories are not open.
Rykov sites the fact that there
are probably 3,300 factories
under Soviet control.
He says that over 1,800
them are closed,
there's no one working there.
They're barred, they're shut.
That's because workers have
run away, they can't be fed,
if they can't be fed
they're not going to work.
And the regime can't provide them
enough food to stay there and work.
It's really incredible the
whole speech and analysis
by Rykov on January 25th, 1920.
And so what happens is
the Council of Labor
and Defense becomes the
central economic planning organ
and it's really through the
Council of Labor and Defense
that Trotsky organizes this effort
to retool and repair locomotives.
If you want to accept the
number 3,800 in January 1920
and they're going down 200 a month.
That gets turned around through
Trotsky's efforts as minister
of transport and then working
through the Council
of Labor and Defense.
And the reason the Council of Labor
and Defense is so important is
that it also organized conscript
labor, especially peasant labor
to go chop the wood
and transport it.
And the main interaction between the
Soviet state and the vast majority
of the Russian population, which
was the peasantry was getting them
to do conscript labor to
get wood because otherwise,
you didn't have a transport system.
So I wanted to wrap up
by saying that a lot
of Trotsky's political career
was tied up with this whole idea
of conscripting the peasantry to
go chop this wood and cart it,
that's what they were doing.
There were limitations on how much
the regime could enforce that, very,
very serious limitations because
it didn't have enough food
to have Red Army soldiers do it.
Red Army soldiers were now
conscripted on a regular basis
to perform labor obligations.
The reason that the peasantry was
particularly an inviting target was
the peasants were told
if you perform your labor
obligations you bring your own
bread, we don't have to supply
it, but then we'll let you go.
That is just the reality of
what happened during 1920.
The story with the industrial
labor force in the major factories
where they need to produce
spare parts for the railroads is
and I have some information taken
from 1920 contemporary numbers,
how much food were
these workers getting.
On average it was something like 15
to maybe 20 pounds of bread a month.
That is not enough to perform
heavy industrial labor.
And I think the most thing
point about the whole chaos
and just the whole fluidity of the
situation throughout 1920 and beyond
because as I said, wood
remained the main source
for fueling the Soviet
transport system long after 1920,
long into the new economic policy
when the food supply
dictatorship ended.
Was that these factories
were not given enough food
and I cite statistics from
these primary source documents.
Some of the major factories that
were trying to produce spare parts
or build new Soviet locomotives a
lot of them were fulfilling no more
than 10% of the orders that
they were asked to fulfill.
There was one factory in the
course of a month produced .9%
of what Trotsky wanted
under order number 1042.
And so what you see is tremendous
numbers of workers being encouraged,
invited, cajoled to come back
to the factories where they were
with the promise that
they will be fed.
And they're fed for a while and
then food supply deliveries,
whatever reason don't work out.
And so there was approximately 100%
labor turnover throughout the course
of 1920 and there's a lot of
very good information about this,
even if it isn't exact it's
close enough to give you a sense
of the fluidity of the situation.
But how do you make this work if
you're in control of the regime,
how do you do this if you're Lenin
and you stop governing bodies.
And the labor turnover for
just the second half of 1920
after they started to get some oil,
a little bit of coal starts to come
from the Ukraine, it was 60% just
during the last six months of 1920.
So I think I ought to wrap
it up here it's been an hour.
There's a lot more that I could
say, I would have liked to say more
about Trotsky's role in
this, but I've got to be.
>> Grant Harris: Five
more minutes if you need.
>> Jonathan Kapiloff: Okay,
thank you very much Grant.
So I guess what I wanted to say is
if you compare the initial situation
as of January 25th, 1920 when
Rykov gives this speech and talks
about there's a separate
bureau [inaudible]
and there's a separate
economy in the Ukraine,
you've got central European Russia
kind of surviving on its own
and most of it if it isn't a net
grain deficit situation it's just
barely producing enough
food to feed itself.
What you see is during the course of
1920 a very, very concerted effort
to start trying to stitch all
of these pieces back together.
And what I can say is that by the
end of 1920 the progress was very,
very limited, very, very limited
partly because the coal industry
in the Ukraine had really
made any significant progress.
There was a key document, you know,
Trotsky brought all of his papers
with him when he was sent into exile
by Stalin and they've been donated
to the Harvard University, there's
the Trotsky archive at Harvard.
And so there's a key
document in there,
I believe it's dated early November.
Thank you.
And he talks about the
fact that the coal industry
in the Donetsk basin still isn't
working at the end of 1920.
You do see some real progress
in the [inaudible] by the end
of 1920 compared to
where it was in January.
And by the way, the first labor
army are created in the [inaudible].
The [inaudible] is
basically Trotsky's,
I don't want to call it
province, but it's his area.
His people are in control there,
they're the ones that are trying
to reestablish [inaudible] metal
industry, the coal industry
in the [inaudible] and so forth.
And what's very, very
interesting again,
the primary source material
is really almost overwhelming,
is that the Supreme Council
of the National Economy despite
its name did not run the economy.
It was just basically the
commissar of heavy industry.
And what you see is all
this territory is recaptured
by the Soviet Regime and
eventually Siberia as well,
within the Supreme Council of the
National Economy there are four
or five separate divisions.
So there is basically a
division that controls industry
in European Russia
and that is separate
and Rykov runs it,
he's the chairman.
But there's a separate,
a whole separate division
of the Supreme Council of the
National Economy just for Ukraine
and it has no interaction
with the Central European one.
And then down here where the Cossack
area is there is a separate Supreme
Council of the National
Economy for Southeast Russia
and there's a separate
one for the [inaudible]
and then finally one for Siberia.
That is still the case
at the end of 1920.
So there is some progress
made, but it's very limited
and I will end here now by saying
that this key monograph that I found
that was published in 1922 it looks
back at the end of 1920 and 1921.
And basically what it says is
that with the limited resources
that the regime had it
started to get some oil,
it started to get a little bit of
coal, coal also from the [inaudible]
that the geographic
dimensions of the area
that the regime was controlling
overwhelmed the resource,
even the limited resource it could
bring to bear when it started
to get oil and coal that simply
the Ukraine remained separate
from European Russia.
The [inaudible] and Siberia remained
separate from European Russia.
And I do believe that that
underlying economic crisis had a lot
to do, not just the issue
about food, had a lot to do
with the recognition by
Lenin and say the government
that they really had to make a major
change and that had a lot to do
with why the new economic policy
was declared in the spring of 1921.
There are obviously other reasons
we know about the [inaudible] revolt
and a lot of sailors and workers
were revolting against the regime.
But if you look at the real
underlying economic reality
of where things stood by 1920 and
the limited progress that was made
by the end of 1921 in effect the
regime did not control the territory
it had won from the
white armies, it did not.
It did several years later, but this
was a tremendously difficult process
and it was a wood economy that
took the entire country back more
than 50 years.
So I'm going to end there.
>> Grant Harris: Jonathan thank
you, that's stellar, that's really.
>> Jonathan Kapiloff: Thank
you, thanks very much.
>> Grant Harris: We'll try if
anybody has a question or two,
this has gone just [inaudible]
now, but any questions right now?
>> So what about I guess within
Soviet Union in terms of trade,
did they trade for oil,
[inaudible] like Southeast Asia or?
>> Jonathan Kapiloff: Okay, yeah
so I want to answer your question,
but let me just you a little bit of
background about what was going on.
So obviously one of the things
I didn't mention was during most
of the Civil War period, certainly
through 1919 there was a major
trade embargo the Western European
countries that Lenin referred to
as the top powers refused to trade
because they were actively
supporting the white armies.
And there's a lot of talk
about there was some
British soldiers dropped off
up here near the Donetsk area
and [inaudible] maybe was 600.
The real ally contribution
to the white cause was
that the armaments given bullets,
machine guns, and everything a lot
of good economic work has been
done equaled the entire production
of what the limited Soviet
arms industry could produce
with the Red Army.
It was a major, major contribution.
That embargo ended in January
1920, it's reported, you know,
in big bold letters in Pravda and
Izvestia and it's very important.
The reality was that there
was no real trade until later.
But what happens in January,
February, March 1920 and I do want
to answer your specific
question is Trotsky's predecessor
of the commissar of transport,
a very skilled engineer named
Krassen [phonetic] goes to England
because the idea is he wants
to start buying locomotives
and there's a Soviet trade
delegation [inaudible]
into Western Europe.
There are a lot of things
the Soviet economy needs
or I would say the European Russian
economy under Soviet control needs.
They need a lot of things, they
need grain, they need many things.
The only thing that Krassen is
trying to get is locomotives.
And Trotsky says in some of his
key speeches in his collected works
and they're really remarkable.
I can just tell you the notes just
in that volume have information
that you won't find any place else.
But basically Trotsky says we won't
be able to get any locomotives.
And in terms of oil
what happened is when --
this is why the regime
got very lucky
and I should have mentioned this
and I want to get to your question.
When the Red Army captured
Baku the big deal was
that there were 200
million poods of oil
that had already been
taken out of the ground.
I don't know if they were
literally in barrels,
but they were ready to be shipped.
And there had been a lot
of destruction to some
of the oil infrastructure in Baku.
And so before 1914 Baku have
seen a lot of information.
Trotsky writes about it,
Trotsky is an incredible writer
and not just flowerily, but he
talks about things in great detail.
He's of incredible use
to anyone who wants
to seriously study this period.
And so up to 35 million poods
of oil is being produced a
month in Baku before the war.
When the Red Army captures it
it's only 10 to 15 million.
But the 200 million that's there
allows them to start using it.
And there's even talk that
given how much they need to use
if they can transport it that
they're going to run out by 1922.
And I'm sure we all have
recognized the name Arm and Hammer.
It was Arm and hammer that helped
the Soviet Union restore this.
And so in terms of trade I can't, I
would think that there's a lot more
in The Prize by Daniel Yergin
and about how much
oil if any was traded.
But basically what you
have by the beginning
of 1920 is the effective
end of the embargo,
although there was no real
trade until late 1920.
Then there was talk of trade
with the Western countries.
And one of the main things that
the regime had to trade was wood
from the far northwest,
from the far --
that's one of the main things that
they thought they could trade.
Because the wood resources of
European Russia not even talking
about Siberia they're more than
a third of all the forestry
in the world at the time
going back to that time.
So just to repeat your question
again, there is some trade.
I think that the regime
needed whatever oil it had.
I don't know if it traded any oil.
One of the things that was very
interesting that they were trying
to trade and it gives you
a sense of how special.
Siberia was a tremendous producer
of very high quality butter
and so there was a tremendous amount
of butter exported from Siberia
for instance to England
Western Europe.
And so that was one of the things
they were looking at trading wood,
butter, those were
the two main things.
I believe they wanted
to hold on to the oil,
but there were other things
they needed technology.
You see during this period that the
entire telegraphic system becomes
totally unreliable.
All the telegraph and coding
equipment was imported
from the West, so they're after
that, you know, anything they could
to restore the telegraph
system they want to do that.
Telephones, telephones were produced
in Russia before the revolution,
but there are not a lot of people
around who know how to fix them
and the skilled laborers
that run away
to the countryside the regime
is looking where are the people
that can repair our
telephones and our telegraphs.
Go ahead.
>> Grant Harris: Jonathan,
I think it was the trade
with Southeast Asia.
>> Jonathan Kapiloff:
Southeast Asia I'm sorry.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Well there was always traditionally,
I mean you can see Iran right
in this little right, there was
a [inaudible] amount of trade
on the Caspian Sea between
Russia and Iran prior yes.
But I don't think there
was any oil going
to Southeast Asia,
I don't believe so.
But I would look at Yergin because
he is really the definitive source
on all of this, it's an
unbelievably good book yes.
I hope that answers your
question at least part.
But no, there's no real large
amounts of trade it's only later in,
you know, 1922, 1923 that
the regime starts trading.
I also want to add one more thing
about locomotive, why was it so hard
to repair all these locomotives.
Well you had all these private
companies before the revolution
producing locomotives, so there
wasn't one standard locomotive.
So if you needed a spare
part for company number 23
that was producing
locomotives in Saint Petersburg
and you couldn't find it
down in Samara how did you
repair the locomotives there.
It was an incredible problem, that's
what Trotsky was looking at of a way
to systemize which spare parts
we had and which we didn't.
And really what happened was
you had and this is the term
at the time that's used throughout
all the primary source materials,
you had what were called locomotive
graveyards because locomotives
that weren't working they were
stripped of their spare parts.
And if locomotive number 23 from
that company in Saint Petersburg,
you know, could be found and
there was another locomotive 23
that needed that particular spare
part it was just stripped away.
And they had, you know, they had
locomotive graveyards of hundreds
of locomotives at a time they
were just stripping them,
that's what they were doing.
>> Grant Harris: I think
we're about out of time.
Any quick question?
So we'll have to end there.
Thank you so much for
coming, thank you Johnson.
>> Jonathan Kapiloff: Thank
you, thanks very much.
Thanks, thanks.
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit us at LOC.gov.